I feel like I know you better than I
actually know you that's definitely a
thing I feel the same for yourself I've
definitely checked out all your socials
and I was like oh I know her oh gosh
it's like I feel I don't know I feel
like weirdly like closer than than we
actually are we've met one time you came
to the uh premiere of the roast of me at
my house yes which felt like such an
intimate experience and I felt so
welcomed and also out of place because I
thought it was like an only fans thing
so I was expecting to be like surrounded
by like my peers and I was like I'm
surrounded by Whitney's fears that's why
you sent me a text you're like ah I
thought it was a real porn stars I was
like yeah comedians like yeah it's
really cool I don't think I had the
opportunity to see only fans in that
light which was really awesome and
really cool to see like I was like
sitting with Alex later on that night
was like I'm so proud of you and I'm
proud of you guys because I remember
only fans before it started off offering
all of these you know expanded
opportunities I mean look it's like it's
like comedy right now I don't know the
case you know
um for porn and and what's allowed on
Twitter and what's loud on Instagram and
what's I know you've had some profiles
get deleted is that why you're there on
your Instagram it's like right now on
YouTube you get kicked off out of the
algorithm to monetize or even taken down
if you even say like vaccine you know
because they're trying so hard to combat
like misinformation that even you know
uh you know Russell Brand had RFK Jr on
who's running for president talking
about the CIA and did the CIA kill your
uncle like and they just like
immediately will take it down they have
to go to a different platform Eve if you
say Q Anon you're not even saying I
support Q Anon or I I believe that
there's a pizza shop where that's crazy
it's crazy apparently you're not
supposed to be cursing right now you
have to like bleep like I know it's wild
so it's like YouTube which used to be
this like Bastion for freedom for
comedians is now becoming super censored
Netflix which is like an amazing
platform comedian for comedians like
Chappelle did that special and you know
maybe it's just because he was Chappelle
and he's so big but he got like so much
backlash for doing jokes that about that
story about a trans woman and you know
everyone's just censoring themselves
like really hard either people are
self-censoring or they're being actually
censored so when only fans TV came to me
I was like what like what what's
happening but I get really excited about
new platforms and New Media like why
like why not you know like when
someone's like oh it's a platform of sex
workers I'm like cool they know where
the money is yeah so you're telling me
this is a platform that's given more
money to women than any Studio or
network in Hollywood where the women
feel safe and they're getting paid and
the money's coming on time and they get
to do it on their terms like I'm
listening yeah you know why not and then
he was like we really want to do some
like you know cool comedy and I was like
can I do roasts which have been
basically sort of like banished for the
most part it's this really um sort of
like classic tradition and comedy but
yeah oh yeah I love roasts everyone's
gotten so sensitive and scared and
saying things that no one would do it
and I was like can we really go for it
and not get censored like for real and
so it was like wow we ended up doing it
on only fans TV which and it's also free
which is like I also think that if you
you know do go watch Comedy that you pay
for and you don't like it like you can
get your money back totally fine so it's
like this is free which I also like too
because I think when people pay and then
they're like well I'm offended and
you're like fine let's just do it for
free if you're offended you can just
turn it off you dork you know yeah so
it's been kind of wild that you know I
think it's going to be like sort of the
next really big home for like uncensored
comedy
hopefully yeah wow that's really cool
like that and I think that like sex
workers and comedians we have a lot in
common because we kind of have 100 we
have to course correct like not only do
we show ourselves we're vulnerable with
people we live to entertain people we
sometimes harm ourselves in the process
because we give away so much you know we
tend to over share whatever people love
us and they hate us sometimes there's no
in between
um so I always feel very comfortable in
that space Also stand up started in
strip clubs in America like the piece
went hand in hand you know it's the same
thing oh my gosh I'm learning so much
already I've been sitting here for like
five minutes would you do an only fans
TV show oh yeah once I like learned
about it I've done one of them it was
kind of like a fear factor-ish and I was
like oh this is really cool and then
like I saw one other one that I didn't
realize was only fans was like a cooking
show that they did I saw like one of my
friends Kazumi on there and I was like
that looks so fun and I was like oh my
God it's fucking only fans TV like what
is this yeah it was like blown away and
then like
um husband were watching and like one of
our girlfriends that's like one of his
friends we were like just we saw like
one of his friends on oftv and I was
like this is fucking crazy and now he
wants to see like we said can I do
parkour stuff on fucking Olaf TV why not
yeah you know I think it's gonna start
branching out like anything I mean it's
like Netflix it's like yeah now the home
for comedy and and you know television
and movies but like it started as that
service that would throw a CD at your
house in an envelope like everything
starts in a weird place yes you know
what I mean like I think you just have
to be like Forward Thinking enough to go
like I've seen this enough times and you
also know that only fans is a reputable
company already so it's like you know
you're not just jumping the gun into
some like weird platform it's like what
else are they hosting what other kind of
stuff are they doing where is this going
who's like it's a whole thing so they're
reputable reputable Honest Company yeah
and I think the same way that like you
know in comedy you want the problem is
like you know people like you can't say
anything anymore it's like no you can't
just throw something on Twitter at two
in the afternoon to to maybe be
retweeted by someone so you're someone
that doesn't follow you is going to see
your abortion joke at two in the
afternoon at work and they're like oh
this is too much and you don't know
where your tweet's gonna come between
you know your Tweet might come between
seven toddlers dead in a school shooting
and Trump is running again like yeah
that's true you know so it's like we're
like forcing comedy on people in the
middle of the day when they're kind of
maybe not in that headspace whereas
comedy's meant to be consumed at night
after a couple drinks when you've gone
into a comedy club oftentimes downstairs
in a literal basement or like you know
this like gritty place you're like okay
this is what we're doing so to me I like
that oftv kind of recreates that
digitally like I'm going here to where
there's sort of this is where there's
some raunchy the conversion is like
we're like-minded people coming here we
want to see some stuff you can't see
anywhere else so it's like you're not
going to go to oftv and be like I'm
offended it's like yeah you know that's
true so it's been like a really cool
safe place like you know yeah for comedy
yeah you said husband let's talk about
it
yeah uh someone that just got knocked up
by someone I've been with for like six
months uh we have a lot in common yeah
we do I'm into it like it's so funny
because like everyone's like wait you're
getting you know pregnant before you get
married I'm like yeah how can I marry
someone until I know they're a good
father I mean there's that we do this in
the wrong order we're like getting
married and then you're having a kid
like I have to know how you're gonna be
with a kid before I sign a contract with
the government I mean I feel like
sometimes also life just happens and
like there's there's that but like I
liked the idea of just being with my
partner and just experiencing life
together and like whatever that is and
not kind of like
withholding ourselves because we have to
be together first for like two years
before we can get married or before we
can consult our children it's like I
think that's stupid so we just felt it
and we just were like you know because I
didn't know him very long I had a
pregnancy before I had Emma actually and
then I ended up having a miscarriage
um but we were gonna keep that one and I
was like Hey like I'm pregnant do you
wanna like I kind of like you I like you
I like you enough to make good genetics
being your baby and stuff like you're
cool and so we just like hit it off so
well and I was like let's just like go
for it and for me like most of the best
decisions I ever made in my life were
spontaneous decisions like getting into
porn and like starting all these
companies or doing like these things
that I do is just kind of been like off
a whim or whatever and like sometimes
when we overthink things yeah yeah we
talk ourselves out of really good ideas
yes a hundred percent so I just like
went with it and I feel like that's like
kind of like what you're gonna just do
like you're going with it I've spent
most of my adult life overthinking
things trying to make it perfect trying
to do what people told me I should do
and it didn't work yes you know half of
marriages end
and most people plan them out yeah so
the odds don't go up or down if you just
do it spontaneously early enough you
know so the people I know they're like
and I waited three years and then we had
a baby a year later and they're
miserable they're you know it puts too
much pressure on something yeah and you
also lose the sense of like finding your
guys's selves together I feel like it
just I don't know I like the idea of
just like we get married and it was like
a lot a lot of the first things we ever
did as a couple were as like a married
couple it's like wow this is the first
time we're at the grocery store together
as a like and we're married there's
something hot about that for so many
reasons because it's like a lot of the
things that I think sour relationship
and cause resentments are sort of in the
beginning when it's like who's texting
you and like we're at the grocery store
like why are you checking out that girl
like if you're not married it's like
what was that about if you're married
you're like she's not cute yeah you know
like you aren't a person you're already
on the same team yeah whereas I feel
like a lot of times when you're in a
relationship even if the idea is to
build towards marriage you're already
going to post teams because you're like
are you worth marrying I'm constantly
testing you yeah to see if you're
someone I should marry and you're
getting all this pressure on someone and
that's usually what makes it sour I
think so I think so I something about it
being spontaneous and just kind of like
happening I think is really cool also if
you're moving in with someone getting
married is not it's not that much harder
to undo I agree you know what I mean
like get a breakup is hard regardless
just don't change your last name if
you're worried about it yeah exactly you
know that's the hardest did you have to
do anything I mean I didn't have to but
I chose to change my last name like you
had to go down to like the downtown I
don't have to go downtown but it's just
like you have to update everything
that's right
Geico I have to update my last name and
Geico and like every every fucking where
it's stupid so it's like that was the
annoying thing where I was like oh it's
a lot more work of like online changing
and then when you decide like I just I'm
curious about the moment where you were
like I'm gonna marry this guy was it
instant or was it kind of gradual
uh I mean I think it was like pretty
much
once I found out I was pregnant we were
just like we're like yo I'm pregnant and
then I was like you gotta marry me
like you know so you're not a woman of
ill repute yeah I was like you know you
we gotta be together like all right
we're doing it and wow because I the guy
that I'm uh with now like he it was like
one thing happened and I just saw
whereas I don't know what this says
about my brain maybe I'm a psychopath
but like there have been times I've been
madly in love with someone and then I
just see one thing happen and I'm like
my heart just shuts down yeah it's not
like a gradual thing for me I think that
happens and then it you know there's
times where I've gotten pissed off at
Pasha and I'm like I don't want to
fucking talk to you go sleep at the
guest house yeah yeah I think it's like
really normal for you to like just shut
down in those ways and then there's
moments where it like picks back up and
like they also I think like do the
things that aren't necessarily arousing
but they're arousing like for me like
it's arousing like when he fucking like
takes care of the dogs yeah and like
cleans up like the dog shit I'm like
yeah you're a man dude my dude man
like clean up horse shit do that stuff
yeah that is that is my when I see
entitlement or when I see someone come
in and be like I'm not handling that
it's just like what do you do who do you
think's gonna handle it yeah basically
you're just saying you're you're gonna
handle it at some point you're just
throwing it to me it's just like I don't
like feeling like I'm someone's cleaning
lady but I love doing chores so one of
my biggest fights with my dude is when
he does my chores because I'm like
you're not doing it religious like don't
touch my shit my biggest thing is don't
help me unless I ask for help don't help
me so much that I can't find my own shit
yeah it makes no sense that the charge
should be here and I'm like but I don't
know where they are and now I feel like
I'm going crazy and he's like put them
in this organized thing like he's the
only person that's like more OCD than I
am I'm crazy organized the same but
he'll his organization is mine's labeled
so that Pasha knows where it goes that's
so funny because I've been writing on
the Chargers
and now they're all gone and is
like how about this this morning takes
my computer because he was like helping
me log into something and he changed Pat
the way my computer interface Works he
changed it to three fingers to swipe
right to go to the next thing
i'm like bitch I've been alive I've been
dealing with a computer 20 years before
I met you you don't get to come and he's
like well this makes no sense that you
do it this way I'm like I look at your
computer and I'm like this is psychotic
he goes up to go down on his laptop
oh yeah I think I go up to go down
it's been a pleasure having you weirdos
dude weirdos three fingers I'm like in
bed you use one here all of a sudden
three but the computer mouse deserves it
but I don't but we were um we were
getting some family members from the
airport and I had you know I have a lot
of dogs like you and there was dog hair
everywhere and I was like okay we have
to clean it like I and it was just kind
of this whole thing and I was like you
know what there's a service that comes
and cleans your car your house let's
just like do that it's like 80 bucks
let's just like schedule it in the
morning I'll just like do it when I wake
up and he was like all right cool and
like 10 30 I couldn't find them and I
like I don't know I'm like where are you
like you know and I look outside and I
hear a vacuum he's vacuuming my car
washing my car and I was like what are
you doing and he was like I just could
not stand the idea of another man
washing your car
yeah
yeah it was just like that that's my
shit yeah I agree that's what turns me
on that's when I'm like I want to be a
dirty girl for you yeah like that was
really hot how you handled that like
that it just it's just like but also you
don't need points for it and you're not
gonna throw on my face later yeah you're
doing it for the Love of the Game yes
yeah and where's your husband is he from
somewhere he's from Latvia
yeah so let me ask you in if you don't
want to talk about I totally get it I
know a lot of friends that went through
the miscarriage Nightmare and do you
feel like that experience bonded y'all
closer and you were able to sort of see
a side of him that oh 18 otherwise I do
think it bonded us closer but sadly he
wasn't like there during it he was
actually in the UK working filming a
project for Red Bull for like a month or
something
and so it actually happened while he was
gone you were alone I was
um but
uh it was okay he was still as
supportive as he could be and everything
like that so um it was definitely like a
hard time
um but did you have to did you just know
I like found out like at the doctor
basically and so I had this like hormone
issue and so the doctor was like take
this hormone blah blah blah he noticed
it was like low so I started taking the
hormone and basically we realized that I
was carrying like a dead fetus but it
didn't detach because I was still taking
the hormone so as soon as I stopped
taking the hormone then it uh you know
expelled did you like how did you ever
it was really really sad it was really
really tough I wrote like this beautiful
poem about it and like it was it was a
really hard experience
um especially because I was like really
eager and it was I had had abortions and
whatnot but like this one I was like I'm
like keeping you and I'm connected with
to you and like this is a a thing and so
it was like really really hard but
I got to like heal from it and then now
I have Emma and everything so you know I
think it was like maybe three or four
months after our miscarriage that I got
pregnant again and so
I was definitely really scared during
that whole pregnancy because of that but
and I was like really a lot more private
as well because I like told like one
family member and then my family member
told all the other family members and I
was like well now you have to go back
and tell everyone that you told that you
know it didn't happen that I had a
miscarriage
um so I was like really secretive about
it
um up until after having Emma and for a
couple of months actually wow because I
was just like I don't want anything to
fucking happen and then SIDS is a thing
and so that was really fucking scary too
because I was like oh my God so like
yeah I have so many scary things
honestly people have asked me they're
like I'm scared of like childbirth blah
blah I was like you should be scared of
losing your child after you have it
because that is the thing that keeps me
up at night what did you just get in a
wormhole of of this online I thought
Googled I've been pregnant I've known I
was pregnant for almost
two months I have not Googled one I'm
like I don't know stuff I just know
stuff is a thing so I just try to do
what I can to like make sure certain
things don't happen so it's like with
SIDS I was like okay I want to make sure
I have the right mattress I have the
right you know
um sleeping gear for her we did like a
pacifier because they say that a
pacifier helps keep them from going into
like a super deep sleep it keeps them
kind of like cautious and stuff like we
didn't want to do a pacifier but I was
like no we're doing one when every time
she sleeps because it says there's times
where I like where she was sleeping on a
fucking shook her because I was like
okay okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I was like
you're okay you're alive okay okay we
live in California that could have been
an earthquake that would have happened
anyway
this is wild that the cause of Sids is
unknown yes that's what's
see I have a friend who's like nephew or
like like their their sister or whatever
it happened to them and it's like we
know 50 ways to keep a man's dick hard
for sex yeah I love you Blue too but I
mean we do not know what causes SIDS if
they believe SIDS is associated with
problems and the ability of the baby to
arouse from sleep yeah that's why they
say to do the pacifier
oh God yeah up until a year so I'm still
she's now a year so I'm like I was like
all right maybe in a year six months
I'll finally chill out yeah but like I'm
still like a little fucking paranoid we
have like the breathing band that tracks
her breathing rate and everything so you
had this happen to someone close to you
yeah but I didn't find this out until
recently I've just always been like
aware of it and so I was like I need to
make sure that this doesn't happen so
like what can I do what are the things a
choking happens okay so I took a CPR
class I fucking did the shit I have all
the things so I'm like I'm like okay I
gotta be like prepared and know how to
at least not encourage it or not enable
it it's it's amazing like how your body
just takes over like I'm finding myself
they're like people like you're gonna
start nesting I'm like I'm I've been a
nesting bitch like what is this going to
look like I was in here last night
reorganizing my Labyrinth figurines I
mean I was like moving do you notice I
changed some of these like liquid death
this liquid death is now in a liquid
death bag I was just like I need to move
things I need to like this is too sharp
this has to go I mean you know I'd like
baby like a psycho and also I were you
really dizzy during your pregnancy I
actually had a really easy pregnancy up
like after like 12 my morning sickness
and first I think my first trimester was
the craziest I was like really hormonal
but I was also like quitting nicotine
then and weird and yeah coffee and so I
don't think it was just yeah I think it
was a lot of other withdrawals yeah I
was a little dizzier before when I was
smoking weed but my balance I just I've
been trying to like stretch and stuff
and I'm like my balance is a little off
yeah it probably is yeah yes wow yeah
your whole thing is changing your blood
flow is like triple the amount now or
something like that did you have a birth
plan I did but I my birth plan was fluid
it was like in the sense of where like I
wasn't like stuck into one place because
like ultimately it's up to the baby and
I didn't want to traumatize myself yeah
I'd be like attached yeah like I ended
up having a c-section I ended up needing
one it wasn't obviously part of my plan
like I wanted a home birth we like tried
for at home but I ended up needing
um I'm personally glad you didn't have a
baby in a bathtub
is it okay if I don't want to have my
baby in a bathtub it's totally fine am I
a monster if I don't want to eat the bag
of poison called the placenta which
animals do in the wild dogs do it get to
hide the blood from predators so they
don't come kill everyone I'm I I'm like
talking to some people like I can't talk
to a lot of La women because it really
is just like you need to have a dolphin
birth you need to fly to Costa Rica and
give birth in the ocean I'm like is it
okay if I just go to a hospital it is I
mean even if you wanted to schedule a
C-section that's like not a problem my
only thing is that the recovery is
gnarly and that's the only reason why I
wish I had a vaginal birth so what
happened when it she just was at a weird
angle I started to get a fever and so I
had already been laboring for 43 hours
yeah we did yeah that was a part of it
as well crazy amount of hours yeah it
was a long time so and then I started to
get a fever and the doctor was like okay
well now you're starting to put her at
risk of her getting a fever and then
other complications arising so then I
was like okay C-section and I think like
an hour two hours later we did a
C-section do you remember it happening
yeah
I was like I can feel that and then I
guess they cut me open because he was
like do you feel this and I was like no
but apparently you can like hear the
tools yeah I was like Pasha distract me
like they're like this is fucking crazy
I know people are like yeah I saw my
wife's intestines in a ball in a rolling
right I told Pasha not to look because I
was like I don't ever want you to have
that Vision stuck into your brain so do
not look I know women that are like I
didn't want to do vaginal birth because
I didn't want my husband to watch me
poop I'm like but you wanted him to see
your spleen I don't care if Pasha saw me
poop that is not my word I don't care if
I pooped and me and the baby pooped and
Pasha also shit himself like what the
fuck ever I just would have preferred a
vaginal birth because like I'm still
recovering and it's been like a year and
so it's like it's still painful I still
haven't felt like my Mobility is lost I
can I I feel my posture is fucked up
because it's like it's like it cuts
through muscles it's funny it's like you
feel even the muscles here are fucked
because it's all connected so it's like
I I've like I have to like fix my pocket
do you have a scar is the scar not that
big it's not but it's not really the
scar that bothers me it's just like the
you can you not that you could feel it
but like I can feel the pain to an
extent still and then did you have to be
on painkillers for a little while in the
beginning I took Tylenol okay it was
funny my nurse was like do you want some
roxies and I was like not because you no
you call Roxy you don't know what rocks
are it's like an oxy it's one of the
Oxys it's like the street Rock Star
Energy drink with Oxycontin no surprised
you didn't I guess maybe I'm from
Florida that's a Florida fucking thing
I'm like this like I know all these you
don't fake rocks no this is I'm not on
drugs this is my personality it's a
nightmare I'm not on drugs either but I
know what they're called Roxy no I know
zany bar Zanny I've heard of that one
Xannies or bars why was your nurse
calling it a ride but it made me why
you want I feel like she did she work
there are you sure honestly she may have
wrote the prescription for herself I
don't know but I was like I'll just do
Tylenol okay now I'm gonna have a home
birth now that I've heard this story
I've completely changed my mind I mean a
hospital birth is great an epidural is
great out of fucking I'm so for that
yeah I just feel like I wouldn't want to
be like high on painkillers when I first
get my baby that yeah someone who I'm
sure my mom was I definitely was super
high at the hospital and stuff like that
yeah so there was definitely like I I
can tell that I was like oh yeah I was
definitely like a little but you fucking
went through major surgery so it's like
and like God forbid you sneeze or have
to cough like it's terrifying well
that's vaginal birth that's a lot of my
girlfriend said when they do vaginal
they pee
oh it just fucking hurts you feel like
your Staples or whatever is gonna
explode that's what's terrifying to me I
don't care about pissing myself
listening and pooping is not of my
worries I'm talking about pain from
being cut open because it goes through
like many many layers yeah and like the
scars like it's like the scar visually
is down here but you could feel this
scar because I cut through so many
different things it also feels like the
scar is too small for the baby to come
out it does look like that yeah I I use
so many questions about that yeah but if
you do C-section you can still do
vaginal for the next one if you want I
don't that's what they say but I'm too
afraid and then I'm also afraid to get
cut open again so I'm just kind of like
afraid to have a second like if I had
vaginal I wouldn't be afraid of a second
kid right right because now I'm like
fuck I can't get pregnant it's gonna
stretch open that fucking
wound basically I don't know kudos to
women who do plastic surgery because
going under the knife was so scary and
I'm like how do you guys do it really I
had my boobs done yeah that's so scary
really yeah it's even scarier to have
one a and one B plus
that's even scarier mine were not the
same size so it was like very easy to
overcome that Terror the scarier part is
that the guy that did my boobs well the
first one I talk about this and um I
think it was like my four specials I
don't want to be a broken record but the
first one I was so embarrassed about
doing it because I'd always had I had
really bad Eating Disorders I talked
about this in my book boring boring but
um
so I my boobs grow it grew in like very
weird later I like different sizes
because if you like restrict your eating
your breast tissue doesn't grow the same
way I also had some scoliosis stuff so
they were just like crooked like and uh
it was always just embarrassing so
during sex I would try to like
straighten them out I just I looked like
I had like fell out of a building like I
was always trying to you know um and so
uh and so I went to this I literally
went to Rodeo Drive and was like looking
for like surgeon like I I didn't I
wasn't Googling it I was like I didn't
want anyone to know I was so embarrassed
I had like the exact amount of money
that I could get
to get breast implants I walked into
this you know doctor's office it had
like gold writing on the front on glass
and I was like this must be fancy and
this is like 15 years ago I don't know
what I'm doing I go up and I'm like hi I
would like to get you know my breasts
like surgically like evened out like
implants whatever and the one was like
oh great are you available tomorrow
morning
for the surgery and I didn't know at
that time like don't ever go to a
surgeon that's available tomorrow
morning you know and then I was like
sure and then she gave me the address it
was by the airport it was literally on
like Airport Boulevard wow don't get
surgery by the airport it's a general
rule went the guy like cut through a
muscle it was like a whole Nightmare and
it was I didn't know enough to know that
you don't do like above the muscle
saline it just it was it looked like two
crocodile eyes coming out of a pond like
it wasn't it's cute so then I had to go
get them redone by this guy Garth Fisher
who's like the best best he was able to
do all this reconstructive stuff and he
told me afterwards part of the reason
his boobs look so good he does half over
the muscle and half under the muscle but
he does it while you're standing up he
puts you like on a cross and you're and
he does it while you're
standing so that they like he can see
how they like fall and I was fine until
he told me that for whatever reason I
just like instantly puked really
interesting he does it while you're
standing up instead of why you're lying
down because you know natural boobs kind
of fall to the side when you lay down
you don't want to lay down and have them
just sort of be up so it's like nuts and
so um you want to make sure that they
fall a certain way yeah I preferred like
teardrop boobs I think that they look
very beautiful exactly so I was just
like I was standing up this whole time
like this is that's interesting like
just like because I was like that just
feels like so much more murdery than
surgery and I don't know why yeah I'm
worried that I'm not gonna be able to
breastfeed because I have favorite no
there's plenty of women breastfeed I
have a friend who's still breastfeeding
her two-year-old and she has had I think
one or two boob jobs oh really yeah but
I feel like a lot of women can't
breastfeed regardless by the way I'm
just like touching my nipple right now
so that was so weird yeah honestly I
think the biggest thing is Kate catering
to your child as much as you can because
most women as soon as they start getting
back into work that was what happened to
me is like at six months I was like okay
let's get back into work I kind of like
forced myself back into work because I
was having some issues up the off at my
office and so I was like all right I'm
fucking boss needs to boss down yeah and
it affected my milk production because
my stress levels went way high up
because now I have my daughter and my
office that I have to function and
whatnot and so like I wish I would have
spent more time with my daughter and
less time focusing on work and it it
definitely affected my milk production
and so I got I feel very lucky I got up
to six months if you are trying to
breastfeed though it's definitely like
keeping those stress levels and like
focusing on like momming as like much as
you fucking can what's something that
you feel like like no one told you then
that like like no one tells women like
your water might not break in movies I
am I water didn't break there's like a
gushing yeah and a lot of women don't go
to the hospital have a pile of water
yeah there's that I think as well as
like you don't I I think I was like oh
my mom had a 14-hour labor so like maybe
I'll go up to like 14 hours I wish I
would have like knew more about the
birthing process if I really wanted to
like do the vaginal birth and everything
because like some women do labor for
like 72 hours and shit like that but
like you know my Midwife and I wish I
had like a better team I wish I didn't
really have a midwife I wish I would
have like family or something like that
like people who are like intimately
close to me and when I say family I also
mean like friends yeah yeah it's like I
mean those people close to you why do
you feel like they were just giving
advice or yeah I just felt like it
wasn't as connected and like I think
that because that's something that they
do it's like oh my usual is like by this
many hours you should be so I was yeah I
think I got a little panicky because I
was like okay I've labored at for 30
hours I was like is my baby okay and so
like I just feel like I wish I was a
around a better team who kind of like
made me feel more nurtured and whatnot
and taken care of than just not that
they treated me like a client but like
it just felt like that very doctory Vibe
yeah it felt very clinical and so it
wasn't like as nurturing and maybe I
could have labored but I just feel like
no just knowing that it's like the
possibilities are endless it could be
really long it could be really short you
may need a C-section you kind of just
have to like
be okay with like whatever the fuck yeah
and I think that that's the best advice
you can get I mean honestly for anything
in life is that like everyone's trying
to get answers But like everyone is so
radically different every baby's so
radically different yeah radically
different like I feel bad that my mind's
been like pretty easy like I didn't
really get a bunch of morning segments I
was tired but I'm just don't feel bad I
know people are like do you have this
you have this I'm like I don't know is
it still in there like I don't have any
of that kind of just like an ox like I
didn't notice till 10 weeks wow I didn't
notice I had like a full I think that I
was similar I was like sweating I was
like fuck it's so hot and I didn't know
and I was like why is it so hot in here
and I'm like some women are so in tune
with their body and that's something
where I guess I was like I'm not that
way I'm not so in tune with myself or
some of my friends were like I knew I
was pregnant I missed my period and it's
so visual and I was I'm not I don't know
this I'm on my period half the time I'm
like what's that like I don't just I
just you know I think I have a really
high tolerance for pain also I'm torn
like I was touring in Canada yeah you're
just not in tune with that your brain is
in focus with other things it's like I
don't need to worry about what the fuck
has happened my body will figure it out
he knows how to Breathe by itself yeah
yeah like women used to do it in the
woods yeah at 12 years old like I feel
like I'll figure this out yeah
um okay couple things I want to I'm
curious so did you say at one point like
were you kind of I feel like I was very
much like I don't want kids I don't want
kids until I did yeah like because
everyone's like Whitney's pregnant like
what like we I thought you didn't want
kids I'm like I didn't want kids till I
wanted kids you know what I mean and
then they'll try to use that against you
I didn't want to have a kid until I met
someone that I thought would be a good
father yeah so I was like let me meet a
father and then I'll entertain the idea
of having kids because I know so many
people are like I want to have kids and
I'm like don't let that desire make you
settle for the wrong person and then we
have one kid all of a sudden you're
gonna have two because you're raising
him also because you were so desperate
to have kids yeah that you couldn't even
make the right decision for a father so
to me I was like the once the father
appears we'll entertain kids I was like
all right this guy's gonna to handle
stuff I'm not gonna have to do this like
let's go and then I think also like the
following step is then it's like you
need to see if your kid is cool with you
having more kids because some people are
like I want to have four kids well it's
like well does your first kid want you
to have more kids does that bet like
does that you get this number yeah it's
interesting to me when people are like I
want two kids I want four kids I want
three kids it's because like I used to
actually kind of be that way and then
now I have Emma and I'm like fuck it
doesn't matter what the fuck I want what
I want does not fucking matter anymore
it's about Emma and it's like what does
she want what will make her Thrive well
having a second child be a good decision
for her or will it not be a good
decision for her let me like look at her
independently and her personality and
her traits and see if having another
child is good for her not for me like I
think like now it's like okay my life is
for her how did you get like this uh
just having my daughter I know but like
you're like just got such like what is
this parenting what is this why like I
don't know do you feel like you had to
break some ancestral curses at all or
like rewire from 100 because you're so
clear and self-aware and like it's very
rare I hear someone talk this long and
I'm not like wow that was stupid like
you're just right
you know I don't know so reasonable I
found reasonable I think it sounds I
think I'm almost too logical and
reasonable to an extent it's to a fault
violently reasonable yeah that's what an
ego list I think well also some of it is
because of my ego in the sense of where
it's like I base certain decisions off
of my life so it's like I've had like
ups and downs with my siblings and a
range of siblings and whatnot
um and so it's like I want I don't want
to provide you know a negative
relationship because I wanted a bunch of
kids you know I don't want to make a
sibling relationship where they're
codependent on each other yeah or you
hear other people where the this they
don't even fucking like each other yeah
yeah they don't they don't talk they
don't even like each other so it's like
you you have kids why because you want
them to have like a friend well like
maybe they don't want a fucking friend
maybe they're not friends and by the way
that logic like back in the day before
like texting and like like that made
sense in like the 1800s oh yeah when you
were like the nearest 12 kids because 11
die well yeah and you needed someone to
like run the farm yeah oh yes you know
like you couldn't have an only child
because it's like the closest other
child was like seven miles away it'd be
a wagon and you would get leprosy on the
way yeah like now it's like we don't
have a shortage of humans I know Elon
Musk likes to say that we have like a
big shortage of humans but it's like
when you fly private you're gonna think
there's not a lot of people around a lot
and go to LAX one time and you will not
think there's a shortage of humans
drives me Wilds yeah go to Disney
there's a lot of yeah that's a lot of it
like go to go to one grocery store like
you have someone you're ask your
assistance about how many people are out
there maybe if he just stands somewhere
and puts a sign saying Elon Musk is here
he will see how many people or not or he
doesn't think anyone's wrong because
people are like avoiding it maybe they
just don't want to talk to you like they
hear you're coming in and they just I
don't know
um okay I want to talk more about this
and I'm sure that it will
keep coming back but I also feel like
you know I've had Angela White on and I
just I'm so obsessed with the women that
do what you do because I feel like
you'll have a very
um specific uh uh unmatched
understanding of kind of like human
nature of uh how to be like
self-possessed to take care of yourself
can I just ask like like and just sex
obviously I know so many women that
don't know how to have an orgasm during
sex they like they're not in touch with
their own bodies
um they don't know where to go they
don't know who to ask and I feel like
y'all are going to be the equivalent of
you know in like NBA players become
commentators afterwards like y'all are
gonna become the sex experts you're
gonna become the orgasm experts yeah
become like the life coaches you're
gonna become like the oprahs that's my
goal there's this porn star Veronica
Hart who I love she actually has like a
character based off of her the redhead
in Boogie Nights is based off of
Veronica heart and um she now like goes
to China to educate women on like their
sexuality and you know feminine hygiene
and things like that because they don't
get the same nor proper educations and
whatnot and it's like she is one of the
women that I admire and look up to like
the most in the whole industry because
she
has developed such a beautiful brand out
of herself from being a sex worker to
now being this sex educator and I think
it is so cool and so beautiful and she's
very underrated but she's like old
school old school uh porn star but she's
someone who I love I felt very fortunate
she used to like work on sets and she
would like be the production manager she
would like cook meals for everyone she's
like this like long redhead hippie
little vegan woman and she was amazing
and I loved her so much and
um she's someone who like I admire and I
want to be like her when I when I get
old I want to be like her and also I
feel like you'll have this like very
like unique relationship with yourselves
where you're able to like combat shame
and not internalize yeah there's so much
shame around sex I mean not all you know
there there's you know rest in peace
August Ames is a porn star who like
committed suicide she like dealt with
like a lot of Shame and things like that
and I'm sure she had other illnesses and
other issues that she was dealing with
and whatnot but it's like she took her
life after like a Twitter public shaming
and thing and it was like really gnarly
and so it's like some of us are you know
thicker skinned and you seem you you see
those girls you see them in the face
front because we're forward and we're
like we're loud and we're proud or
whatever but like
there are definitely girls out there who
like struggle and don't do as well
because it's a really tough job like you
have to have a really tough skin like
that might be a part of like why I am
the way I am and Angela White is because
we're fucking thrown shitty shit all the
time but to be fair when I was a little
kid some kids would call me like gorilla
girl or wolf woman and I would just be
like hooting like a gorilla or howling
like a wolf because I was like oh you're
gonna throw them like how like I don't
fucking care yeah like you can't hurt me
yeah like well I think it's fucking
funny like yeah yeah so I don't know
like and it's like the I mean you know
being a female comic is like you know I
stay with the most hated species of
person on the planet because you don't
get to see us naked and you just like
hear our opinions you know we sound like
this you know so it's like you know to
me it's like always like you someone
can't get you if you get yourself first
yeah you know what I mean yeah someone's
like like you're annoying it's like yeah
I agree like I'm trying like we yeah all
the notes you have about me like I have
the same ones like you don't need to
criticize me I'll like I'll I'll take
I'll take it from here yeah
self-loathing like I got it I had a view
on that you know but also think like
boundaries like how do you have to set a
lot of boundaries in your life it seems
like you know I was talking to Adriana
chechik about like her agents like
pushing her so hard and like you know
being on sets and being able to like you
know I think you know I think every
woman in every workplace and every
person in every workplace has to set
boundaries make sure they're not being
used make sure they're not being taken
advantage of like you know for me I've
learned with boundaries is you can't
like speak your boundary all the time
you just have to remove yourself from
the situation you know because if
someone's not honoring a boundary the
boundary is not for them it's for us so
to say like hey you can't talk to me
like that or hey like I'm leaving at
seven at seven thirty you can't go hey I
was supposed to leave 30 minutes ago you
just had to leave yes yes you know so
it's like you can't agree verbally
advocate for your boundary like do you
have like you know Tools in that space
that
yeah I mean I'd say so like I definitely
am that type of person where it's like
I've had to leave sets where I I left
them and I've I've definitely set
boundaries like certain girls I think
you know kind of do feel pressured into
ways and but I feel very grateful
there's times where I felt like I could
have been kind of pressured but other
things like the universe was like on my
side my like Guardian Angels like the
first scene that I ever shot was uh I
was an extra but they were actually
trying to get me to be a performer on it
but I had my period at the time so I was
like I can't fucking shoot a porno while
I'm fucking bleeding and they're like
yeah there's this
a makeup sponge you put a makeup sponge
in your pussy someone just tried to talk
to me about this yeah and I can't
Tana uh Mojo sorry it's so panicked
about pronouncing her last name I don't
know mangui I don't know I have no idea
mangui I don't know how to say
Tana we all know who Tana is
I'm like don't screw this up don't screw
this up and then um you can FaceTime
that bitch right now yeah
she's in what and why is that your name
why are people yeah is it a stage name
or is that her legal last name God I
don't know I mean isn't she from like
Vegas she's from Vegas so whenever
everyone's like she's crazy I'm like for
being from Vegas she's doing pretty well
um I think she's in uh Turks and Caicos
Turks and Cake House or she probably
pronounces it differently knowing the
way that she spells shit so yeah I'm so
panicked and where am I oh so yeah she
says you put like a beauty blender in
your pussy
is that to not get pregnant too oh or
just to stop bleeding it's just to stop
you from bleeding okay but it's still
some blood still can come but so I've
seen the way y'all are carrying around
your beauty blender these women that
just have a purse and they'll just pull
a loose Beauty blender out of their
purse like Psychopaths don't put that in
your this is literally how Cove had
started you guys you cannot these Beauty
blenders are not being sanitized y'all
are just putting them on floating around
in your purse it makes me so nauseous
so which by the way I used to have this
this OB
and uh she would just give me all this
information for no reason like that was
just like the most invaluable
information she'd be like you know you
know do you have your period coming up
and I'd be like yeah actually but it's
annoying because I'm going on vacation
and she'd be like oh well what you
should do is put in a tampon soak in the
bathtub and then pull the tampon out and
then put another tampon in soaking the
bathtub until it's full and then take it
out like a way to like get it out
quickly and it works
it absorbs all your menstrual blood
because it's the the uterine lining yeah
because it's already if you put it in
you let it Bloom it's already wet it's
gonna take it out I'm trying to say this
in a way that's not making people
totally gag while driving but yeah it
really works you can really speed it up
interesting
good games
and there's also some pill I don't think
it's spironolactone but it's a pill you
can take that's not approved in America
um but it's they have it in France that
helps your period go faster like if you
have a vacation coming up total side
note I loved my gynecologist when I had
Emma not that he was a good doctor he
always forgot my name he's a good doctor
but like he he told me he was like he
was like uh what did he say he said
something about like don't get fat like
he's like like he's like you're getting
fat like don't this is why there should
not be male gynecologists honestly if
fucking I was so happy he told me I was
like thank you no one else will fucking
tell me that's a wild thing to say
though wasn't mad at it because look I'm
a big fan please don't get fat yeah and
I don't have any stretch marks I look at
how I got back in my yeah I know this is
like I'm not on that ozempicious energy
no no wow that's it's just my nape I
just have really good genetics as well I
was like this before but I ate good I I
started to gain a lot of weight in the
beginning and my doctor was like why are
you fucking getting fat because my
fucking doctor was like you're getting
fucking fat and I was like fuck me Jesus
Christ I love it if you go to a female
gynecologist she's like a guy you gotta
kiss your fucking ass and massage your
feet and she's not gonna tell you you're
getting fucking fat in all these
horrible stretch marks I was so happy I
was like you are the realest
motherfucker in this fucking room you're
the only one who told me that I was
getting fat thank you but what were you
eating that was like dude I was like I'm
fucking eating for two yeah I know I
know I was like two peaches I've been
two peaches like you know just like I
mean I eat healthy but like I would eat
a lot like okay two peaches is gonna
make me fast no I by the way I just Pat
knows I just got a whole thing peaches
delivered and I cut them up and I put
them in butter and brown sugar
yeah I love peaches Aren't Enough sugar
for me I have to add Brown sugar and
butter and Grill them they're so good
sounds fucking delicious no I still love
I eat brownies and like Walnut brownies
and all that fucking tasty shit too so
can I ask were you I feel like I was
watching you on something talking about
like smoking weed I have quit I quit in
like like late January and I'm kind of
thinking maybe I quit I don't know we
could talk about that in a second but
did you you obviously quit you know do
you feel like you're gonna go back to it
uh I do smoke weed again and why do you
what do you do it for because I have yet
to be able to do it without having a
manic episode publicly yeah no I
definitely when I first smoked weed
again I was like what the fuck am I
doing what the fuck kind of parent am I
at why am I smoking weed like oh my God
like I need to focus on being a right
parent for my daughter and I definitely
was like little fucking uh let's see if
it relaxes you that's a good thing to be
relaxed around your kid I guess but like
I definitely think like it fucks
is watching our daughters so me and my
husband would like smoke some weed we'd
be chilling in the hot tub and I'd be
like fucking come true yeah that's
really good for your marriage and I know
so many women that are like dealing with
postpartum depression I'm like look I'm
not a doctor like they call me ho Rogan
but you know it's like there's so much
sleep deprivation and the Strat like
smoke some weed if it if it relaxes you
but I found that I think as my mom died
in December it's just been like you know
it was it was she was in a bed for 12
years like for whatever reason when I
had real things to worry about we didn't
calm me down like it did make me more
creative it just made me like sort of
more paranoid and it doesn't chill me
out maybe I'm just like doing the wrong
one it makes me kind of like manic like
this is like how I talk normally without
anything so people already think I'm on
like Adderall and stuff so it but it
didn't it doesn't chill me out do you do
Indica is that what I'm doing wrong I
don't know if there is like a strain
same thing yeah my husband's more like
that where he's like I like this one and
I was like a fucking weed is weed I
don't fucking women tell the difference
hormonally you're a different person
every day yeah yeah so there's like no
way to an extent I just felt like I'm
like this worked yesterday like this
should work today but like and it's a
completely different experience like I
would do it if I felt like I feel like
it's like gambling for me like one out
of every five times is like awesome I'm
like creative I'm clear I'm like oh I
should apologize to that person and like
oh I should read like I'm gonna buy a
gift for this person yeah I definitely
don't think it should be used as a tool
as like you're going to always expect
some like you know thrill or rise out of
it you know sometimes I think it is just
like a fucking smoke weed and watch TV
yeah or whatever but like
um I definitely find that I can be a
little bit more absent-minded so like I
try to save it for like night time and
whatnot so where I don't need to be like
as like you know
full Focus full forward for thinking but
I definitely mean I think me and Pasha
are thinking to quit uh pretty soon as
well because we're like okay we want to
start parenting ourselves and like
that's something I never did before is
like policing myself so I'm like I need
to police myself and like my verbal
Communications like sometimes I'm like
I'm on the phone making like sales calls
I'm doing these brand deals I'm trying
to do this I'm trying to like sell my
agency I'm trying to like do this stuff
I'm pitching models I'm like recruiting
people and I'll just be like on the
phone phone saying stuff or like some
people call me Riley and I'm like oh I
don't realize it may be Posh will pick
up and he's like
don't call her Riley at home yeah you
know like things like that it's like
okay we need to like police ourselves
more I need to like make sure I start
like you know being a little bit more
not letting as much slide I feel like I
feel like that's the other thing it's
just policing yourself you let a lot
slide when you suppose I'm almost like
too forgiving yeah there are I wish I
started to get into the habit of it even
like myself I say the word porn I say
porn a lot so it's like maybe I say
adult you know just say adult yeah
instead of porn that's interesting you
know like policing certain words that
maybe the average person wouldn't
fucking have to be talking worrying
about porn but like I'm selling porn
every day yeah so it's like I need to
like police myself more so that's
something I've like learned I'm like
okay Emma's she's one she's really
understanding stuff she's talking yeah
so like I'm like okay it's happened real
fucking quick and all of the parenting
stuff I hear it's like it's not I see
people that work so hard to parent their
child and control their child and like
create discipline and I'm like and then
their child is like that and I'm like at
the end of the day you have to parent
yourself they do what you do yeah just
do whatever you do yeah they're not
gonna do what you say they're going to
do what you do so just be the kind of
person that you want your kid to be and
model that behavior and that's gonna be
it exactly you cannot tell your kid to
do something and be a hypocrite yeah
they're just going to do what you did
and they're gonna go like oh and then I
could also be full of shit too yeah I
mean yeah but that's like so cool
because like I feel like we're both in
businesses and I guess it's like you
know maybe anyone where you you're only
as mature as you hold yourself
accountable to be like in comedy like
you can stay a kid forever people will
buy tickets they'll clap for you they
love it they want you to be like
immature like a mess forever yeah and
like you can get away with a lot so it's
like really up to you to make sure that
you mature and continue growing and
don't just like stay stuck 100 do random
question are you gonna tell your kid
that about Santa or anything like that
okay I'm glad you yes
this is oh oh this is me and my dudes
number one fight I was like I am not
gonna lie to my child about anything I'm
just not gonna lie to my child about
anything I cannot lie you're with it you
decide to have a baby with a comedian we
can't lie to a thought we cannot lie two
things
[Laughter]
I'm so riled up right now because he was
like you're gonna take away the magic of
Christmas and like if our kid is so dumb
that it can't put together that Santa
came down a chimney and we don't even
have a chimney we've got a big we need
to get a helmet for that kid we got a
learning disability on this kid number
one number two I have a friend that
asked him about this I was like the
Santa Claus thing Spooks me and he was
like interesting you brought that up
because his kid you know it was like
five this past Christmas said oh here's
some gifts from Santa Claus and the kid
was like like there was a man in our
house that got creeped out because the
whole thing is don't talk to strangers
yeah that kind of thing and they're he
was like they're like oh yeah he came in
the middle of the night and brought you
presents and he like got terrified the
idea that like what do you mean there
was a man in our house that came in here
like got scared which is like I don't
know maybe I don't know they do a good
job with the magic aspect
yeah
like I don't like sitting on some random
alcoholics lap at the mall that's always
felt weird to me every photo we were
always bawling crying I also I think
it's I think the thing about Santa that
bothers me more is the naughty and nice
of it all that we use it as a way to
control our kid it's like it's like when
when parents are like panicking it's
like surveillance for your kid it's like
if you don't act this way you're not
gonna get a present which is like that's
not why you want a kid to act a certain
way 100 and I had a friend who was
telling me they she's done Santa for a
long time but she's pretty sure her
eldest kid knows that he's not real but
she has like there's certain things it's
like Mom I want this for I want a
PlayStation she's like that's like
that's too expensive I can't get it but
Santa doesn't have a price limit so he's
like okay I'll just ask Santa for it
this year because they write it on the
thing a list of things that they want so
she's like really into the magic of
Santa but so she's like I'll you know
here's the five things that you ask for
Santa so he's like he knows to
manipulate his own so he knows his
mother's been manipulating him and so
the Santa being so he learned to
manipulate her and to say I'll just ask
Santa for this really expensive gift
that Santa can get that my parents can't
afford but Santa can't the magic of
Christmas yeah
I don't respect my parents at all like
so many things I agree where I learned
about it from like Sam Harris so I heard
a podcast and he was like there was
tying don't lie to your kids like don't
lie about Santa don't teach them that
there's this real thing because then
they learn that you are just a big fat
fucking liar and what else can I believe
that you've been telling me for the last
five fucking years of my life for the
last seven years of my life it was my
real dad you know but also it's not just
Santa it goes into the Easter Bunny you
know it goes over Jesus
[Laughter]
like Jesus and Spider-Man they're just
fictional characters that are in some
books and like but it's really fun to
have the most fun it is fun it's fun to
see Spider-Man at the thing and you ask
for a photo but you know that's not a
real Spiderman yeah he's like he's not a
real character that is an aspiring actor
who does not have health insurance who
will be unhoused in two weeks he can't
be an actor that's why he's wearing a
Spider-Man costume he can't show his
face but it's interesting because you
know I I understand that served its
purpose like before the internet and
stuff like that but I remember I think I
remember
more feeling not like my parents are
lying to me because I feel like that
already happened a lot like I went to
like a Catholic School everything felt
really we would go to church and we
would go like don't do this don't do
that and then I would see it be done in
the home so I kind of was already like
okay adults are kind of Hypocrites but I
was I didn't think it was a bad thing I
kind of like oh this is just a deal with
adults okay it's like you kind of don't
know you know we would go to you know
like this is the body of Christ and I'd
be like this kind of just tastes like a
shitty wafer like I remember like
because I always had to question
everything like this is the blood of
Christ I'm like this tastes like what's
in my mom's Cup every night yeah you
know in the end what's in her coffee mug
in the morning like I I kind of was just
like don't trust adults but I remember
Santa thing I knew it was like cosplay I
knew it was not real but I remember
seeing my dad's handwriting of Love
Santa and just being like like you're
not even gonna sell it yeah like at
least sell it at least make up a
different handwriting you know what I
mean yeah it's like you don't care
enough to even yeah do that just don't
do it at all like I remembered that I
remember just being like this just feels
like a sloppy version of what every
other kid has and I'm like never gonna
have a parent that like puts you know
effort into the mat like you gotta
really go for it if you're gonna go for
it yeah I don't know but then you get
that fucking manipulative child over
here that's looking we'll also go for it
from you if you're manipulating you're
gonna get a child to manipulate that's
what you're modeling for them so to me
yeah I think the idea is like but also
like you don't want to have the kid
that's gonna tell someone at school well
yeah I mean of course it's a shitty
fucking kid they're gonna be like watch
Whitney Comics kid dude the kid is gonna
be a downer it's gonna like no yes
because I think it'll probably be pretty
fucking funny I feel like but my kid is
gonna be the ones like Santa's not real
at like three and like ruin it for all
the other kids like I know that's gonna
be the case so I feel like I have to say
like most kids believe in this yeah I
don't want to lie to you yes it's like a
super fun mascot yeah
and that's exactly what it is he's like
like I said he's just like a Spider-Man
it's not like you don't Spider-Man's not
fucking real yeah you know we don't have
Gotham City it's not anywhere on the
fucking map yeah yeah it also I mean
It's tricky because then I was looking
at my dude I was like well then I have
to go like he's he doesn't have to be
white like it just gets too weird like
why is he white why is everyone white
all these magical figure like Easter
bunny is a little spooky also I remember
when I did believe in the Easter Bunny
no I'm sorry the Tooth Fairy Oh yeah the
Tooth Fairy yo the Tooth Fairy I would
knock out my own teeth yeah because I
wanted to get the money my parents used
to leave computer video games under my
pillow which I'm like that doesn't seem
good for my neck but like they would
stick computer games under my pillow
instead of money you had a lot of
siblings I I had a couple sort of
running out of yeah which also that took
away some of my Santa magic because then
I I was never like Santa's not real it
was like you need to wrap the presents
and sign it for Santa for little brother
so I was like oh okay like you're
telling me Santa came in here wrapped
the presents with our wrapping paper no
no I'm wrapping I know but it's the same
wrapping paper as our wrapping paper oh
yeah no none of the presents were ever
from family it was always from Santa oh
mom never did any it was always Santa it
wasn't okay I get all the credit I want
my kid I did all of this
yeah no it's a lot of effort it's a lot
of work and it's your hard-earned money
that went into that and so I feel like
and it's like you thought of what they
like and stuff so I think it it you
should get that credit and it's like I
look at me I fucking pay attention I did
all of this I pay attention to you but I
also would get really shitty gifts like
I literally my parents would just like
wrap up shit from around the house that
I I'm like I know what this is the
Atlantic City talk exists when you were
younger is that why they did it no
literally I'd be like Mom this is my
cereal bowl this has been my cereal bowl
with my name on it for the past like
five years I don't think Santa gave this
to me that's so interesting I'm glad you
asked that because I've like I've I've
felt like oh I guess I'm just this like
bummer of a person but I just lied to so
much as a kid I just want my kid to
always be able to come to me and no if I
don't know the answer I'm not gonna lie
and say that I do about something or if
I go you don't need to know that yet I
agree that's fine but I'm not gonna lie
I agree that's kind of where I'm at as
well I'm like Santa he's not a thing we
think it is fun I still do Christmas I
still do decorations you know but it's
just like he's not real I'm like a
Christmas maniac and um you know but
yeah but say I interesting yeah you're
the Christmas Maniac not Santa okay
fucking you a couple like like granular
questions you're allowed to pass on any
of the ones you want
um were you worried at all
that being married would hurt your
career this is coming from someone that
has had that insecurity before and still
kind of does uh yes yes I thought like
being married and having a child was
gonna be a hard choice on my career but
I was at a point to where I was willing
to sacrifice my career for that because
at that point I had already actually
kind of like retired from like boy girl
porn because I wanted to find like the
love of my life and I knew I wouldn't
find him fucking other guys and still
shooting porn so I was like okay I
fucking have to quit doing porn so like
I quit before I'm like a year or two
before I met Pasha and then um I love it
when a bitch's plan works I love it when
a plan works yeah you were just like I'm
sad reality that wasn't the initial plan
the goal was to meet a guy while I was
shooting and him be fucking chill with
it but like that just isn't the reality
of it you're like I need to do this like
when I see women that are just just like
in bad relationships like well I'm
waiting for the one I'm like you have to
make space for the one oh yeah you're
not vibrating anything that a man would
be attracted to that isn't equal for you
like you have to make the space yeah you
have to be ready for the person when
they arrive the kids are sampling once
they get there but I love that it just
like that worked yeah yeah it worked it
was it was really good so uh but I I
knew it was gonna you know like I said I
had to retired from boy girl porn so
like I took that that Financial hit
basically because I was like all right I
am ready to feel valued and you know
happy in my personal life I got that
gratification from my work life I have a
successful sustainable living so I was
willing to Forfeit that so yeah I did I
did get it and I I still took the hit
but now I'm putting my Endeavors in
other places like my agency so it's like
yeah maybe I don't make as much doing
porn but now I have an agency that's
like now I was maybe making this much
and now I'm making this much but now I
have an agency so it's kind of like back
to where it was I just I'm putting my
eggs in more pots I love that and as
someone who is an aspiring lesbian
no I I I was seeing a girl for a little
while but uh I mean a couple times I
know did you say did I read somewhere
that you were dating a woman in high
school or I guess you'd be no it wasn't
me did you ever I mean I never dated a
woman I definitely like entertained
women but I'd never like dated one
anytime I started to like kind of start
talking and whatnot it just like like oh
he's got a little
shading a woman is it's a lot of voice
memos
I can't do voice memos it's like six
minute voice memos and this was back
when if you if it stopped you had to go
all the way to the beginning again
this is before they figured that out I
mean it's a lot it's a lot but I think a
lot of women I know are kind of like I
think I'm bi but like I don't really
know what to do and like would you
recommend like girls that want to get
sexual with other girls to like watch
porn first
um
I mean yeah maybe maybe try try to find
some like I guess porn that is more to
your style of like maybe what you're
looking for intimacy wise uh but
um I think that it could give some
helpful things but like a lot of like
porn shows like fucking hardcore finger
banging even like the girl on girl you
know some sometimes those girls have
never had sex with other girls before
like there's plenty of times where I
shot with a girl and it was like her
first fucking time with a woman and I
was like okay that kind of hurts but
like I'm filming a video so I have to
pretend that it's like really good but
like okay like I need to like coach her
a little bit because she does not know
what she's doing so like not all lesbian
porn is like genuinely like you know
girls that like girls having sex they're
just doing an impression of what they
think they're supposed to be doing or
what was or what the director's telling
them or oh yeah or what they think is
good because also they might be doing
what a guy I fucking did to them and
obviously a guy doesn't have a fucking
pussy so he finger bangs it and he
thinks he knows he's hitting the right
things but he's not so like I feel like
maybe you know not every porn or porn
performer is someone who is in tune with
their sexual self so like it is I don't
recommend like using porn as your you
know tool of work I think maybe explore
yourself a little bit more to find out
what you like to send think of like
maybe what will she like you know like
but I think it's also good to have a
sense of porn and the spectrum of it
because there are a lot of different
issues and you may be with a girl who
wants you to choke her and you may be
with a girl who doesn't want her to and
if you get that wrong you go to prison
so communication is key
consent to get your children taken from
you if you have any yes
can I ask because I think that like guys
can I think guys are confused too I
think there's a lot of porn out there
yeah
same fucking thing you know you're
putting on a show as well so like your
comedy that's not how you fucking talk
to people and everything like I mean you
might be pretty animated but I don't
know if you're like that when you're
having a conversation with somebody I
moved more than a porn star on stage off
stage I'm just a blob yeah I don't think
porn is like where you should get your
education I hate when people are like
porn's bad because you have like people
have porn addictions and I'm like that's
that person like any fucking addiction
is like are you gonna say coffee's bad
because people have an addiction to it
or like those I don't know I don't know
it's like true life is a thing people
have addictions it's it's a thing
there's rehabs opening up for cell phone
addiction now I've I mean it's like a
major major yeah it's like people have
to learn to police themselves maybe we
don't need to always police what the
product is no not in the slightest yeah
and you know I'm just curious like like
for guys out there like what would be
like your number one like turn off or
something you just like see like that's
I think this this is fingering like that
is one well yeah that's just don't do
that every one and then if you're like
uh and then they'll be like two fingers
then you're like whoa let me just uh I
don't know I mean I think the thing a
lot of guys don't understand is that you
need to kind of do come hither a little
bit Yeah but in a little softer and I
think um I guess I don't know a lot of
people probably say this often it's like
when you're when a girl is getting close
to coming like don't change whatever
don't change what you're doing don't
change my God that's probably my worst
thing not only do you ruin the orgasm
you now fucking piss her the fuck off
and now she's shocking I'm fucking
annoyed with you and she is like I'm
like I don't even want some anymore what
is that I get pissed like now let's
change position are you out of your mind
yeah now you now you want me to try to
reach that Peak again after getting
pissed I have 14 no veins in my forehead
you know something is about to happen
and you're just gonna stop and go go
change your your this playlist like what
are you where are you going yeah oh God
that makes me insane well sometimes I
wonder I'm like maybe they have like a
charlie horse or maybe they have carpal
tunnel no fuck no fuck that shit you
swallow it like a man and you handle
that shit and you have endurance and
stamina and you try like your life
fucking depends on it you do it like
there's a gun to your head
that's like my life mentality and
honestly that's the only way I can come
is if he has a gun in my head that I
found that I literally if I'm about to
have an orgasm I will just say don't
move just keep don't move don't change
anything you're doing like I have to
yell you know that's a at least in
parenting that's something that I've
learned that is not good to do because
if you let's say you uh you let's see
hang on let's you don't want elbows on
the table you say you don't say don't
put your elbows on the table you say
let's keep our hands in our lap exactly
don't say don't tell them thing not to
do give them a con a different action
that would solve it yeah because when
you when you say don't look at that the
first thing I fucking want to do is look
at that you know it's like keep your
eyes on me okay keep your eyes on all
right instead of look over there that's
so genius I was I'm reading there's this
book called hunt gather parents that's
saying when it comes to like chores and
stuff always let your toddler do chores
with you even if they're making a a
bigger mask oh yeah they just want to do
what you're doing so if they're sweeping
instead of saying no no I'll do this you
go play yeah or even if it takes like
two hours longer with Emma with her
fucking bows every day we spend like 20
minutes letting her empty all the bows
and then we try to put them all back and
a lot of times it ends back up okay
let's try put them back but this is the
deal it's a kid they're figuring out how
the world Works they're trying to
understand how long it's gonna how many
times they can do it they're testing you
yeah figuring things out laundry takes a
lot longer but you let her fucking help
let her help and then because if you're
going to know you go play because you
think it'll be faster without them then
they learn oh it's my job to play while
mom is working yeah and then when she's
eight or ten you're gonna have no chance
and you're teaching her it's a chore in
lieu of play whereas they'll just see
chores as fun play time yes yes yeah
that's true yeah my mom did have a good
thing with that word it was always like
music and fun and dance and cleaning and
la la so like cleaning was always like a
positive it was almost like a family
bonding moment and they say don't do
charts like this is when you do this
chore and this is when you like don't
make it homework like it's just like
part of eating is like doing the dishes
you know it's like just as fun of a part
I love that I saw you jerk a guy off
with your feet who's uncircumcised now I
I'm sorry that's a weird segment I have
been with guys
I'm having a boy and I'm don't
circumcise them I'm all over the place
on it don't do it one I think it's like
just like an extra worry for you as well
as like that's like a little baby
surgery I would see that I would never
The Cutting I would never do there's
already so much research in of saying
how Trump traumatizing that is on the
baby for a Litany of reasons it
desensitizes does all these things yeah
listen for Emma even just like when
we're at the hospital they had to
fucking do a blood prick on her feet to
you know check the blood they had to
fuck and she's crying and it was so sad
and then like one time because we're
still learning was like she got a really
bad diaper rash and it was like it was
so sad to like wipe her little butt and
her be crying and she was so sad and it
was like if I had a little boy and I did
that surgery I would be so sad and like
well like it was just it's sad for them
to be in all that little pain and like
it's just unnecessarily they're
associating it with you they're just
going like this is something's happening
under your watch they're saying that now
and look I'm half Jewish I'm allowed to
do this which is like you know because
you know it's obviously very important
in the Jewish culture is like showing
that um uh you know men that were
circumcised have issues with women the
two things I will say number one there
is like now like a ring I guess you can
do that just dissolves it a little bit
and it's supposed to not hurt I need to
do more research on it but the argument
a friend of mine made which is like
it's a big it's like a lot to process
I've had you know both my parents in
nursing home so I'm kind of like it
resonated a little bit which was one of
the biggest issues in uh when men get
older in nursing homes is infections if
they're uncircumcised my mom when she
was in nursing homes got really bad UTIs
and would get sick all the time and like
so yeah they're not cleaning your
uncircumcised dick when you're in a
nursing home it's kind of weird to be
like I'm gonna do this now so that when
you're 80 and you're in a nursing home
you don't get a dick infection but like
that is one of my friends made she was
like I didn't want to do it it was
horrifying she has two boys she was like
it was my nightmare and then I was like
reading about that and I was like I
don't want my yeah I mean I do know that
there are men who will get a lot of like
even like yeast infections and a lot of
times the fix is to like get a C-section
or a C-section a fucking uh circumcision
an adult circumcision yeah I hear they I
haven't heard it one that's of one
that's gone great yeah oh yeah I just
have friends that have two friends that
have done it and you know doing it as an
adult must be pretty yeah yeah I
couldn't imagine doing it as an adult
but yeah I've I've heard of that being a
thing but like I'm also just kind of I
don't know and educate proper hygiene
yeah well that's like a really good like
hygiene flow and routine from such a
relationship to clean a baby dick
they're like a thimble yeah I feel like
we have to do it to make sure it stays
clean I'm like I got that I got time
yeah well yeah I don't yeah but even
like I think as they get older it's like
trying to establish a really like
healthy like hygiene routine then maybe
it would just resonate to them their
whole life and even when they are old
and 80 they're like no you gotta fucking
clean my dick really fucking good I
don't care that I'm 80. you fucking
clean my dick like there'll be a lot of
my school invented some some invisible
dick cleaner by then yeah that's what
fucking 80 years from now like that's
I'm sure it'll be figured out and then
my guy friends they're like don't let
him know oh man like it'd still feel
weird and it's ugly and I'm like dude
what's ugly no that's what I'm saying
I've been with uncircumcised guys like
it it's easier to give hand jobs
actually yes it's way easier you don't
feel like you're bombing or like yeah
getting super dry yeah yeah
in a movie theater or like an animal and
it it's kind of there's really no
difference otherwise I mean when it's
not hard
it has a little bit of like it gives a
little yam energy but it's like fine
yeah but I don't yeah I I honestly think
that it's kind of stupid for anyone to
think that it's like ugly or blah blah
blah blah like vaginas aren't like
they're not Universal yeah it's it's not
Universal and so like for someone with a
vagina to be like I don't want any extra
skin flapping around it feels a little
bit like throwing snow yeah I don't know
I just feel like it's like Arjun our
genitalia is like it's not Universal
they're all different shapes and sizes
or whatever and I just think that like
having the foreskin is like how the dick
is supposed to be we don't do any like
weird vaginal things or whatever we
don't need to do it anymore because of
the hygiene purposes and whatnot so I
don't know I think that it's just kind
of like
just like I don't know weird to do
there's so many men who don't have a
circumcised penis and they're fucking
fine so it's like I don't know I I think
it also to an extent depends on like
what the father is because like my
husband's not circumcised so if we had a
baby we wouldn't have them circumcised
so that they're like the fucking same
yeah yeah so he's not like why is Dad
like this and I'm like this like and and
whatnot and like Pasha knows how to like
clean himself he knows what it's like
and so there's that because like I've
had a director who was talking to me
about his son and his son he was having
to tell his son he has to like pull his
Fork skin back and basically like
masturbate more so that he can pull his
foreskin back while he's erect because
it it was being painful to pull the
foreskin back because you have to
stretch it as the penis grows you have
to be able to pull it back and make sure
it's stretching so you you have to
practice like Care on it as well and
encourage like masturbation and pulling
back and that you're you're getting
erect to an extent you know so it's like
um my husband has the experience of and
he remembers it being painful at one
point and having to like stretch his
skin so like he has that knowledge so he
knows how to parent his his son but a
guy who hasn't had right right he's
already had a circumcision he's not
going to understand how to parent that
and maybe make sure you talk to your
fellow guy friends about like true I
can't like ask one of my guy friends I
was so happy when the director was
telling me about this because I was like
I wouldn't have no idea why would I know
by the way thank God we don't know how
eight-year-old baby's dicks work this is
a good thing yes but as a parent you
know I was like oh my God thank you
because if I have a little boy I and I I
know that I will not have a c-sec I keep
saying C-section a circumcision you have
PTSD yeah I do but I wouldn't have a
circumcision and so I would have to know
how to like properly care and raise and
make sure that he knows and it does its
thing that it's supposed to do like yeah
yeah it's a lot it's a lot to think
about it is it is a lot I always said to
myself I was like I'm not going to do it
I won't do it like it's it's you know I
think there's a lot of things we keep
doing because we've kind of always done
it and you know were there anything last
question about um childbirth was there
anything in the hospital like I know
there's those eye drops like those
vitamin K drops like there's some things
that people like you can do you can't do
it's just been something we've been
doing forever I'm always curious like
what are we doing today yeah we're still
we're doing the eye drops so that they
don't go blind for something so I'm like
okay fucking yeah dude yeah yeah why
medicine
amazing
so uh we did that and we did what was
the other one uh there's also something
a friend of mine was like if you have a
C-section you're in for a couple days
they don't need to take the baby every
day to get a bath like they can do one
yeah I made sure there was no baths um
on we actually gave Emma our first bath
I think like in the sink because she
ended up pooping herself so we're like
okay we're gonna give her a fucking bath
or whatever and so
um but yeah you can like be like really
there's like this whole thing I can send
it to you like this mama natural she's a
little too natural for me but there's
certain things in in her book and like
little lists of like she had this great
list which I didn't realize it was even
a fucking thing but it's like to have
students or not have students like one
of my friends didn't say to not have
students and so there were students
observing nope yes no you wouldn't
fucking think that you have to say that
but you do of course not yeah there's
like weird little things like that where
it's like you that's kind of like the
stuff in your birth plan that you have
printed out where you're like okay you
make sure you don't do this there are
definitely no students you definitely
like don't do this or whatever some of
the other things you're like if you need
to fucking end up in a C-section fine
but like you're definitely not ever
getting a student in here while you're
c-sectioning me not dude you're all on
Roxy if you think I'm gonna have
students witnessing my birth I mean
someone has to be a doctor at some point
yeah but there's YouTube videos for that
VR there's got to be a better solution
cadavers what a night
yeah
I'm obsessed with you oh I like you too
you're just so you're so clear you're so
like like I don't I mean I'm just I'm
I'm enamored by you oh oh thank you
thank you I think you're really awesome
I was super stoked to like learn about
you and like oftv presented you as like
a opportunity type I was like I can meet
this person she's a tangible human who
is this woman oh my God no it's been
really cool because I feel like you know
as a comedian I don't know if it's just
female comic but you kind of always got
to go like all right am I gonna be able
to tour forever like I've always had
kind of a business brain too and want to
do other things and I'm going to create
shows and I want to like do this merch
line I'm gonna do all this kind of stuff
and I mean Joan Rivers was one comedian
you know she had QVC stuff and she had
jewelry but I feel like there's a little
bit like you know in in your space
there's so much more like let me start
an agency let me have a doll let me like
do this other thing and like you got
like there's just such a like uh the
opportunities are endless you know type
of thing and that's the goal I want to
think more like that yeah as a as a
comedian you know I don't think anyone
wants a mold of my vagina you would be
surprised you should actually reach out
to fucking flashlight you know what I
might do it that would be so it should
just be my mouth because men probably
want me to shut up so much that they
could they have them they have the mouth
ones like put a dick in Whitney you have
a really nice mouth too thank you I was
actually thinking about that she was
like she probably gives a really good
blowjob she has like a nice big mouth I
was like Shane Diesel would love Batman
I have big teeth though too I mean you
know I'll tell you what some people
Shane Diesel would like that who's that
how do you not know Shane Diesel I don't
know Shane Diesel you've probably seen
his penis before is he so is it the one
with the birthmark uh
that's James Dean right oh he's Shane
Diesel's a black gentleman Shane Diesel
was he a magician what
I thought I thought he was I saw him do
magic one time oh that's Vin Diesel
yeah I couldn't I couldn't fit his
you could fit it in your mouth
I mean the fact that the movies make
that much money is nothing short of
magic okay I'm gonna be doing some
Google yeah I don't think I could fit
his I fit it in mine penis in my mouth I
think you could what's the uh uh dread
best Oh I thought you could say biggest
I was like big biggest dress I've heard
all about drugs yeah since I've been
working with only fans TV all I hear
about is Jack yeah and dragon kegels are
always in the same sentence Oh keep like
doing keyboards exercises have you done
Kegel I mean I guess you didn't have uh
birth actually so but I did the Kegel
thing before or whatever I I that was
what I was telling you there's this
there the pelvic floor therapist that I
was going to recommend to you why does
it have to be called pelvic floor I
don't know but I will say I have this
horrible hip pain and I couldn't get rid
of it couldn't massage it out it was a
muscle that was inside my vagina that
she had to push on on like the inside of
like my leg kind of and after she would
massage that on the inside I would get
the relief that I was looking for I am
feel like I have pains in the weirdest
places and I'm like is this an abortion
or a fart I never know what's happening
you should you probably need to like
massage like the muscles that are inside
your vagina that like are connected to
your legs and shit
yeah it's interesting is that available
[Laughter]
are you a fella ball
um you're such a dream oh you're a dream
thank you so much let's talk about it
only fans TV show idea yes please so
good yeah so good and these super
awkwardly don't ride elephants I love
you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign